c'est sur son podium qui vaut tant que
la cultissime r8 gordini tressens
accueille les visiteurs à modèles
produits de 1964 1970 dans les usines
renault grâce à la rencontre entre année
des gordini et pierre dreyfus
le patron de la régie cette voiture le
modèle qu'on pouvait commander lorsqu'on
a métier son concessionnaire pour avoir
une renault 8 gordini
ce modèle ci est un modèle très 101 qui
fait à peu près 100 chaud mais il y
avait un modèle 11 cents qui était un
peu moins puissant et qui n'avait pas
une 44 phare gordini est devenu un mythe
pour des générations de fondus de
l'automobile car c'est italien a
naturalisé français et pour eux le plus
grand génie de l'automobile
amédée gordini l'état mécanicien hors
pair c'était un génie on l'appelait
d'ailleurs le sorcier
car d'un moteur qui faisait 25 ou 30
chevaux il en faisait sortir 50 ou 60 et
il a commencé sa carrière de
le compétiteur dans les années trente
cinq avec simca fiat
l'exposition retrace le parcours no ce
mécanicien de génie constructeurs
d'automobiles de course pilote même
toutes les voitures que son génie
améliorera sont présentes y compris
cette date c'est un véhicule daf cdaf
est équipé d'un moteur renault mais de
base mais celle ci est une des dix
exemplaires à peu près il y en à peu
près une dizaine qui ont été équipés
avec un moteur renault 8 gordini ces
voitures étaient destinés à la
compétition mais surtout sur la glace l
on est champion de france sur la glace
pour réaliser cette exposition le club a
bénéficié de nombreux frais en plus des
collections du musée des collections
très variés à découvrir également lors
de cette visite comme ces plaques
émaillées et affiches d'époque est là
derrière et très spectaculaire remise en
état de ce modèle français suaire des
années vingt par les membres de
l'association